l'alternance l'alternance est en marche
l'alternance est en marche en marche et
grâce à vous plus rien l'arrêtera
rienarrêtera rien ne
l'arrêtera l'alternance est en marche
rien j'ai d'abord voulu rassembler la
famille il y a trop de souffrance en
France trop d'inquiétude trop d'angoisse
pour l'avenir pour que nous nous payons
le luxe de division qui n'avent aucun
ance j'ai ensuite voulu que nous nous
engagions pleinement dans la bataille
des départementales aujourd'hui notre
famille politique dirige 68 départements
jamais dans l'histoire de la République
une formation politique n'avait connu un
tel succès l'alternance est en marche et
rien l'arrêtera hier les élections
départementales gagnées par l'UMP udi
par cette union et surtout je crois par
des valeurs portées par des candidates
et des candidats qui croyaient en
alternance dans leur territoire
l'alternance est en marche il n'y a plus
d'espoir qui est possible du côté de ce
gouvernement mais l'opposition elle peut
incarner un nouvel espoir nous avons
commencé à le faire sur les conseils
généreux en corrigeant les dérives de
laassistana en commençant à travailler
sur une baisse de la dépense publique
qui permettra d'épargner nos impôts le
gouvernement a refusé d'entendre le
message des électeurs nous devons donc
poursuivre sur ce cheminlà et
l'accentuer encore au moment des
régionales l'alternance en 2017 c'est
une longue marche c'est une longue
marche avec des étapes la première étape
c'était les municipales nous les avons
gagné la deuxième étape c'était les
départemental étape franchie la
prochaine étape ce sont les régionales
les régionales qui auront lieu les 6 et
13 décembre prochain les régions ont une
force majeur le développement économique
les transports la formation donnons de
meilleures compétences à nos jeunes
soutenons nos entreprises protégeons
mieux les femmes et les hommes qui
créent la richesse par leur travail
encourageons la recherche cherche
l'apprentissage les lycées
professionnels la formation l'activité
économique ce sont les régions qui ont
ces compét désormais quasiment
intégralement et nous allons pouvoir
encourager de nouveau l'activité pour
préparer l'alternance politique au
niveau national en 2017 et autour de
valeurs républicaines qui doivent nous
permettre de transcender leséclivage
partisan et bien nos régions reconquises
pourront renaître l'espérance oui
l'alternance est en marche et rien ne
l'arrêtera
[Musique]
maintenant nous devons continuer
préparer le
projet fonder une formation politique
dont la règle de fonctionnement sera la
démocratie nous nous réformons nous-même
nous transformons notre mouvement
politique avec un un mouvement qui sera
plus démocratique qui sera plus
transparent qui sera plus moderne aussi
qui fera meilleure place au numérique
par exemple tout simplement pour
solliciter nos adhérents sur sur ce
qu'il pens sur ce qu'ils veulent chaque
adhérent doit être respecté chaque
adhérent doitêtre écouté chaque adhérent
doit être considéré la voix des
adhérents sera enfin entendue
l'alternance est en marche rien l'arrê
le succès dépend de chacun d're vouso
d'une opposition prend ses valeurs et
ses idées et on a besoin de l'incarner
au moment des régionales nous comptons
sur vous rassemblez-vous
unissez-vous prenez parti dans cette
formation politique que nous allons
créer ensemble nous avons besoin de vous
parce que la France a besoin de chacun
de ses
citoyens